we used to go topless bars strip shows
i have no idea that you used to do that
that was fun i liked it
fatherhood it's father's day coming up
soon
about two years ago the try guys made a
motherhood series for mother's day so
we're doing a whole fatherhood series
one video every day that's all about
dads
[Applause]
is it rude for me to say i want out the
try guys are going to become fathers
no we're not we're gonna become deadies
no
or at least invite our dads to come in
from across the nation
to let us know how terrible was to raise
us more accurate
[Music]
so today we're recreating photos of our
dads in an aim to better understand who
they were when they were our age i think
many times the father-son relationship
is the least developed in the family
his life starts when i was born but
before that he's
just like us i don't really know a ton
about my dad which is why we want to do
this whole series let's get
daddy'd daddy's
it's weird there's some photos i look at
my dad and i'm like i don't recognize
that man
and then there's some photos i'm like
wow that's my face i doubt he knows what
day this photo was taken but my dad is
rocking a
mean porn stash is it weird to call your
dad stash a porn stash
it's a porn stash i think my dad and i
are really similar in a lot of ways my
dad and i talk about music
and we talk about football and that's
kind of it
when i check in with my parents about
how my life is going i call my mom i
want to get advice from him
and we don't do that i know my mom
always says that my dad was funny
i don't see it apparently that's how my
dad won my mom and god knows if i find
somebody that's going to be how i do it
a lot of my memories are playing outside
with my dad so my dad is a doctor
but he kind of took some time to figure
that out he was actually
a tennis pro for a while i always think
of my dad as a clean cut guy his
hair is long my dad has never had long
hair i definitely
got my competitive nature from my dad we
would play a lot of sports growing up
and he would always beat me my dad would
play the sports that he was good at we
would play tennis
we'd play squash we'd play ping pong we
never really played soccer
i love my dad he's great he's a big old
nerd when people always talked about how
tall he was he'd say yeah
he's gruesome you think your dad loves
puns my dad invented puns i don't know a
ton about my dad's life before
me the only thing i know is that he is a
mining engineer and he was in a
barbershop quartet
called the four ever yours
[Music]
i mean come out music is really one of
the biggest ways that i think my dad and
i
have bonded so i thought if i was going
to make anything of my dad i should make
his
iconic foursome with my iconic foursome
how different the try guys could have
been
you know when i was a kid i really hated
my dad
he was never home he had to work about
two hours away so for a chunk of my
childhood he was never there for five
days a week
every time i saw my dad he had to play
the disciplinarian roles in retrospect i
feel really bad for him because we did
have a lot of
issues growing up but i think a lot of
it was just
the expectation of what a man should be
in his family and then my parents got
divorced
my dad versus jay are two different
people
jay is the man that came out of the
divorce he became
everything that i think he was destined
to be which is a good person
with a great sense of humor i'm very
excited to learn
what this moment was in this hammock
where he's like dreamly looking up at
the sky
that would warrant that smile when i was
a child i would never see that
expression on his face
daddy daddy daddy daddy
[Music]
they're just like hey adam yeah call me
adam
i'm adam kornfeld and i am zach
kornfeld's father
hey dad hi zach i wanted to be in the
music business since i could remember
i was eight or nine years old i used to
listen to casey kasem's american top 40
and i was hooked he loves rock and roll
i remember listening to the beach boys
and the beatles and bob marley and i
look like freddie mercury's like
pudgier brother i'm about the same age
as you are now in that photo
it was on the beach on fire island uh
one of my favorite places in the world
your grandparents actually met there
in the late 1950s that's a happy memory
photo
i'm jim i'm ned's dad um
and then i don't know what i'm talking
about after that
i mean i've played practically every
sport it's not as popular nowadays but
in the 70s tennis was huge
god it's such an action shot really
jumping out at this
we sometimes joke that i'm really
obsessed with marriage but i think i get
it from
my dad he will do anything for his
family
every summer in fact i've never missed a
summer in my life my dad
and my mom we go to this place called
the thousand islands
crowds would come out to watch these
tournaments that we'd have this
photo of me in one of the tournaments
react to the left you know even just
recreating this in a photo studio is
tough
i don't think i fully realized how good
at town as my dad was i know this smile
of my dad's very well
he has one smile i'm don habersberger
i'm keith's
father he has two other sons you have
two others
did i say that i love her i'm recently
retired
and i spent over 40 years in the mining
industry
i was in choirs ever since fourth grade
i began going to
barbershop practices and got into a
quartet the four
ever yours solo play on words
music was the the part to balance my
my life with
[Music]
i'm eugene's dad i was 41 year old
when he was born kind old
i guess he's relaxed now because he's
retired but he had a pretty stressful
life
even in this photo i have no idea if
this was taken in korea growing up in a
war-torn country i think
does something to you i kind of used to
be dreaming
all i was thinking about was like a john
wayne and cowboys
that's all right in the movies it wasn't
like that when i came to us
what was it like oh it's a very
conservative country you have to work
very hard
trying to make money trying to support
families
for an asian family and for an immigrant
family
we don't share stories to begin with so
to force my dad to come here and talk
about that stuff on screen
is pretty uncomfortable for both of us
he seemed happier before he was a dad
how did your life change once you had
children
it was i was so happy
hey dad hey zach how are you i'm great
welcome to buzzfeed
nice this is where i work wow
wow great shirt choice i like yours too
would you normally be doing right now
playing gold i don't really know about
you
in between college and my birth the in
between is like really foggy and hazy
yeah for me too yeah show us
that photo
we got the same belly same chest hair
pattern so handsome you're just saying
that because i look like you in this
photo
yeah i have bigger nipples than you yes
bigger than most people
yeah i was probably listening to bruce
you are an east coast dad yes baby we
were born to sin
you and mom are both like crazy
workaholics i think that's why you love
the beach so much because this is like
just the only place that you
turn your brain off that's true this is
my weekend relaxation
moment your job like my job it's it's
your life yeah suns being similar to
their fathers
it's horrifying okay let's see it
that's a good likeness that's a nice wig
you got there thank you where'd you get
the rackets they don't have those
rackets anymore
ariel had a racquet that she picked up
at a flea market
so this is during a tournament oh a
tournament yeah this photo suddenly has
stakes that i didn't realize yeah
were you the reigning champion yeah wow
yes
that's something that impressed mom no
she is impressed by that kind of stuff i
mean
that's what i looked like when i dated
her
[Music]
what was her deal anyway i was very
immature how so
i did some pranks i would get really
frustrated easily as
i've gotten older i've gotten more wise
than i used to be
interesting about to turn 30 y'all
looking at the original photo i already
look pretty similar
so here is here's the new one oh look at
that
is it different right definitely not
adopted
we had a lot of outfits i don't know how
many we had but um
this outfit a few years later was what
i was married in i don't think i
connected the two
right and these were the ones who were
you know best man and ushers at the
wedding after the wedding
we performed
[Music]
and the last song we performed was a
song called the auctioneer and they
auctioned me off
and patty your mom got me she bit on me
and got me
did any other woman give her a run for
her money no no they wouldn't dare
i also bid on
our voices blend very well because we
have the same voice
[Laughter]
these three guys are uh part of my
groomsmen uh so we decided we would
photoshop all of us
into your photo
are you ready to see it sure all right
let's see it
that's you yeah just like me
yeah i look better than you are yeah
that's true can i start asking him
questions
okay so where in korea was this taken
no it was houston texas what why were
you in houston
i was medical training where was my i
was
i didn't marry that time until and
you didn't move to america with mom no i
was single
you were single in america yeah for
you're six years five years yeah you
never listen no you never told me
did you have sex before mom well there's
a lot of room goers
wait plural huh more than one yeah
were all of them korean no what that's
when i didn't be there right
now what were you thinking about in your
photo
i was thinking about my future
i changed a lot since i have a silly kid
you know i became better person i have
to we went through a lot of
fertility clinics really yeah i did a
sperm test too like your
try guys i don't know you're trying so
hard to have kids kyle explains a lot
we tried to hold up the kid what
yeah then she became pregnant yeah it
was
the happiest day of my life when my
city came why haven't we talked about
this before well anyway
you know we're getting old so nothing
too high
that's true all right um cool dan
cool uh i'm enjoying being a tri dad i
want you to know that dry dad
there's a lot more because we've got
four more you know
you know i told you we're actually doing
like a whole week of videos with you so
hold on tight
daddy all right
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah i'm a cartoonist if you tell
me
a scenario i can draw you a cartoon
within a few seconds
oh man i would like to see a
uh a monkey eating cheesecake
at a fancy table i can do that